in a previous video we used this theorem
to evaluate certain types of composite
functions in this video we'll do a few
more examples that get a little bit more
involved so let's say we wanted to
figure out the limit as x approaches 0
of
f of
g of x
f of g of x
first of all pause this video and think
about whether this theorem even applies
well the first thing to think about is
what is the limit as x approaches 0 of g
of x to see if we meet this first
condition
so if we look at g of x right over here
as x approaches 0 from the left it looks
like g is approaching 2 as x approaches
zero from the right it looks like g is
approaching two and so
it looks like this is going to be equal
to two so that's a check
now let's see the second condition is f
continuous at that limit at two
so when x is equal to two it does not
look like f is continuous so we do not
meet this second condition right over
here so we can't just directly apply
this theorem
but just because you can't apply the
theorem does not mean that the limit
doesn't necessarily exist for example in
this situation the limit actually does
exist
one way to think about it when x
approaches 0
from the left
it looks like g is approaching
2 from above
and so that's going to be the input into
f and so if we are now approaching 2
from above here's the input into f it
looks like our function is approaching
zero
and then we can go the other way
if
we are approaching zero from the right
right over here it looks like our the
value of our function is approaching 2
from below
now if we approach 2
from below it looks like the value of f
is approaching 0 so in both of these
scenarios our value of our function f is
approaching 0. so i wasn't able to use
this theorem but i am able to figure out
that this is going to be equal to 0.
now let me give you another example
let's say we wanted to figure out the
limit as x approaches 2 of
f of
g of x
pause this video and we'll first see if
this theorem even applies
well we first want to see what is the
limit as x approaches 2 of g of x
when we look at approaching 2 from the
left it looks like g is approaching
negative 2. when we approach x equals 2
from the right it looks like g is
approaching 0. so our right and
left-hand limits are not the same here
so this thing does not exist
does
not
exist
and so we don't meet this condition
right over here so we can't apply the
theorem
but as we've already seen just because
you can't apply the theorem does not
mean that the limit does not exist
but if you like pondering things i
encourage you to see that this limit
doesn't exist by doing very similar
analysis to the one that i did for our
first example